cela pointe bonjour bonjour et merci de
nous accueillir ça me fait plaisir que
la pointe on a tellement parlé des ch à
celle des dents les nouvelles depuis
deux ans des problèmes plus énormes des
drames que rina vous vous connaissez
aussi l'autre côté c'était la bonté et
la générosité des gens qui travaillent
le corps ou intel je lis moi au cs que
deux des frères georges sur la rue
saint-urbain les préposés la plupart
sont gentils et montrent
prudents et prennent soin de leurs
patients c'est sûr que c'est pas comme
chez soi mais c'est plus chaud
matière mas que un hôpital c'est
important elle dira aussi parce qu'on
parle que des problèmes c'est ce que eu
des drames épouvantables mais c'est
important de souligner aussi que c'était
des milieux de vie il ya des gens qui
dédient leur vie est gentil avec des
personnages il peut pas faire de
discernement trucs sont rémunérés ce
qu'ils ne sont pas pressés pour la
différence mais ceux qui s'occupent de
leurs patients beaucoup
même s'il a dû récemment passé quelques
mois dans un siège celle des jean
lapointe se souvient de tout
[Musique]
de ses débuts dans les années 50 où ses
talents de chanteur et d'imitateur vont
lancer sa carrière
de la grande période des cabarets à la
casa loma au théâtre national
eh bien ils sont 2 il y en a qu une peur
bleue de l'avion et l'auto contraire il
est très bien dans les nuages mais les
deux ensemble ça fait une belle percée
mais j'avoue là c'est ça la main
qu'on va danser
en fait
se souvient de son collègue et frère de
saint jérôme lemay avec qui il formera
le fameux duo les jérolas jusqu'à 74
odienné
il se souvient comme si c'était hier du
tournage la même année en
1974 du grand chelem les ordres de
michel brault
tu vas le design
lapointe aura bien sûr vos chansons
l'histoire de la scène extraordinaire
melior bon je vais commencer par le
cinéma ouais moi à mon âge l'âge de 58
ans vous m'avez marquer non mais c'est
vrai les ordres vous avez fait de grands
rôles est important de l'histoire du
cinéma du québec ne vous êtes conscient
de ce oui oui les ordres c'est surtout
les hommes qui aux deux banques séquence
plat
on m'apportait kokou 1 perd ses plumes
déchets ce premier contact que j'ai à
l'extérieur depuis qu'on m'a arrêté
c'est je prends beaucoup
l'aimer mais tellement puis la force de
cette prise non
c'est michel un
réalisé c'est prenant sa moyenne loin
mais aussi
un teddy une ce prêt si ces terres où
maintenant pour moi c'est agréable à
faire il ya pouvoir y vient d'éprouver
si bien pas de savoir
s'il reste du canada
on
va sacrer dès le 15 puis pour vous
mettre dans vos personnages
comme duplessis parlez moi c'est comment
vous avez travaillé ça c'était de
limitation au début c'était produit
l'incarner c'était comment vous avez
réussi à faire un personnage qui était
si fort je peux pas vous répondre de
faire patrice parce que je ne sais pas
j'arrive à m'isoler
comme ça
c'est resté comme ça
exactement comme ça
tout le long du tournoi
j'ai oublié
la voix lit les gestes de certains
duplessis que je t'aime mais se voit que
gm a requis ces personnages que j'ai
inventés blessures qu'ils ressemblent
pour un monsieur du plessis mais je mets
le jouet présent quand vous avez vous
dit apanage fédéral provisions vous
d'abord j'avais déposé et quand vous
avez filmé les ordres 74
174 dix ans vous aviez ou même moment ce
combo l'eau avec l'alcool tout même
moment à peu près là ça pourrait glisser
loin d'être réglée
mangeant des légumes partie mais c'était
pas complètement je sais pas
complètement sans rejeter cependant
dommage c'est sûr mais je vais les fêtes
ça m'énerve
un peu
est ce que avec le recul c'est le combat
le plus difficile que vous avez menées
dans votre vie
quand l'alcool
entre oui mais je mange en invitant au
passé un vainqueur
j'essaie de me rappeler
puis je suis assez habile à oublier
parce que dans votre autobiographie et
monsieur lapointe que vous décrivez des
pages j'ai rarement lu des pages aussi
clair pour nous faire comprendre ce
qu'ils ont pas un problème d'alcool à
quel point quand quelqu'un soif il soit
vous raconter cette scène c'est à
l'hôpital saint luc mais vous le
raconter on comprend rue mais c'est
parce que je les fais ce jeu les vécu
j'étais à l'hôpital c'est lui qui en
effet pas parce que j'avais pris une
balle une brosse et puis hier matin
sorcier parce qu'il m'avait enlevé me
soulier puis mes vêtements jeux
s'obtient par anton faveur des femmes
mais à l'époque la rue saint-denis
envoyons toutes sortes
inaperçu ou presque je suis rentré dans
la mort et j'ai mal exactement solde est
double qu en est il de bien
comme on appelait cela l'époque chez soi
pourquoi alors ces sols et puis
monsieur sauver de l'hôpital coupe deux
fois puisqu'ils m'ont frappé si que j'ai
marché une journée dimanche matin mais
t'es sauvé de l'hôpital
j'ai un marché ce groupe affronte m et
puis j'avais prêté pas pour marcher
pardon j'ai pris un taxi il demande au
chauffeur qui s est récemment passé de
la bien j'avais acheté une caisse de
bien
je m'étais assise au parc lafontaine
frein bas
est rendu après deux bien j'ai réalisé
le ridicule de situation
j'ai laissé les bières proprement
survenus à l'hôpital
le lundi vous êtes entré en cure oui
puis c'est la chance de votre vie oui
et puis eux
pour un moment du fait de très utile de
sauvetage d'etel
mais je dormais moi
c'est ce qui est pire qu'un pseudo
repartir experts pour
une finale mal journée à l'effet d'une
réunion ont dit le notre père
j'ai senti comme une chaleur intérieure
envahir mon corps j'arrêtais tremblay ce
désir d'aider des autres c'est venu tout
de suite après ou présents jean lapointe
deux heures moi j'ai eues j'étais aider
mais ce pauvre est que je vois pas aider
les autres sont comme ça quand on a
ouvert la maison à l'appoint
reçu est allé moi-même un traitement sa
mort c'est sûrement sauvé le
la maison jean lapointe est à 40 ans
cette année
quarante mille personnes y ont trouvé de
l'aide
alcool drogue je cyber dépendance hyper
connectivité l'objectif elle-même
faire face à ses problèmes de dépendance
trouvé la force
d'apprivoiser c'est dément de vivre avec
[Musique]
et depuis 2004 la maison mise sur la
prévention
six cent mille jeunes à travers le
québec ont participé à des ateliers pour
les sensibiliser à la consommation 1
elisabeth sa fille est nommé à la
direction générale de la maison jean
lapointe est en 2019 ce sein que la
maison jean lapointe fait beaucoup de
bien et puis
moi ça me fait plaisir tellement plaisir
cet art donnant qu'on soit sain vieux
cliché mais reste c'est vrai ça c'était
de long peut pas s'en sortir tout seul
non donc ça prend une aide
d'abord fois essayé les alcools et canal
m c'est vraiment miraculeuse ont ici ça
marche pas et les ors bas alors à ce
moment à l'eau
en traitement il ya pour que la maison
jean lapointe d'autres centres qui sont
très bien aussi
encore beaucoup
[Musique]
j'avais eu un rapport avec l'argent un
peu comme avec l'alcool vous en avez eu
beaucoup temps avait consommé beaucoup
oui
beaucoup
ce que tu as une bonne année il avoue
faisait beaucoup d'argent huawei si ma
mémoire est bonne j'ai donné une année
je donnais vue semble à l'impôt et je
vais faire un mini enceintes des miros
montagne a longtemps aux
samoa pour ce période de produits
c'est la vie vous donc j'ai fait ce que
j'ai pu faire dans votre chanson merci
vous êtes j'ai fait que j'ai pu puis
j'ai essayé vol puis des fronts tampon
se relève ouais
même si je ne te propre parfum
j'ai fait du mieux
je prouve
on
j'en apprends que je vais vous parler de
votre période politique
votre père était député les gens se
souvient de votre père était député de
matane matapédia
matapédia matane matapédia matane ont
fait dérailler été député de 35 à 45
fait la guerre ouais donc la politique
vous si c'est quelque chose on parlait
du plessis tout à l'heure vous avez
incarné avec brio la politique si vous
l'avez dans le sens le goût
le support
grandi je dis c'est pas quelque chose
qui est loin il pas par nous raconter
des histoires de guerre surtout pas ce
papa y est allé il fallait de guerre
puis
moi j'étais tout torreilles to view it
avec un papa nous racontait des
histoires de guerre
sec me frapper de plus ces quelques
jours ne sont pas en mission train est
atteinte soldats et puis ils sont
revenus
4d est un bon raconteur pas par se taire
et monte pour lui il m'a tapée lui vous
dis ouais parce que vous avez une vision
un peu pessimiste la politique l'a vu
cette sortie de ben 10 ans où le sénat
ça vous a gardé des souvenirs pas tous
bombe dont ceux comme ça ouais
c'est aussi non il y avait des bonnes
choses qui se faisaient vraiment alors
c'était très vite il pas reconduit avec
des pertes de temps incroyable c'était
ce que faisait suer le
jeune et en mourir
c'est l' api demain tout vix n'est pas
assez efficace
mais c'est trop long les procédures sont
trop longues
moi j'aime pas pardus tain c'est que ces
jeux il ya des modes j'étais malheureux
à moudre aux senneurs
malheureux peut-être mais il y reste
quand même neuf ans jusqu'à l'âge de la
retraite obligatoire à 75 j'ai lu remet
en et vous savez dit parce que vous dans
une mer bleue
indépendante c'est sale époque les
artistes exit loto-québec là tous vos
amis étaient indépendantistes et vous
justifiez des rallys bas à cause de mon
père qui avait été député deux ans mais
j'avais fond de forte baisse et ça je
m'en viens là votre expérience au sénat
où vous avez comme vu qu'ils avaient
comme deux solitudes vous l'avez
véhicule les deux solitudes
savez je sais que des anglophones qui
nous aiment pas beaucoup mais comme nous
le sortent un anglophone quand même pas
beaucoup mais quinté prix dans deux
bateaux aviv avec l'eau c'est pas la
même chose learn aperçoit qu on pense
pas pareil on n'est pas fait par ai
lleurs jeannette ou là sur le québec
canada
ça va venir un jour ou l'autre et
dépendances québec je souhaite vous
souhaitez maintenant pour jouer vraiment
et moi j'avais parlé beaucoup avec rené
lévesque je leur ai qu'un homme vraiment
charbin il était très sincère très en
lettres puisque je parle beaucoup avec
ferrer beaucoup beaucoup chavirent sur
l'aide de son ami félix rey fier
d'entendre ça le jean lapointe est
fédéraliste de père en fils qui vire du
rouge au bleu mais au delà de la
politique qui les a si pu séparer
finalement on sent bien toute
l'admiration de jean lapointe l'artiste
pour félix leclerc le gère
vous étiez proche amand les eaux étaient
je l'aimais beaucoup
c'était rare pour moi
j'en avais de longues longues
discussions
quand il lui était départ l'ancien moi
je te fédéralisme
il
s'agit à présent la face et lexis de
même tu as fait ça avant sa cuisse mots
dictés dû répondre
jésus tu penses que tu es produire à
comprendre
ni vous respecter or beaucoup il était
fait pour moi et un tellement gentil
et puis quand tu es décédé
ma femme à l'époque m'avait téléphoné
j'avais commerce fils et aiguilles
justin l'atteindre agissez comme ça que
ça s'appelait et puis à moitié chez
mieux te le dire de suite voilà prendre
de toute façon dans l'eau mais s'est
laissé deux années
j'allais m'asseoir même une heure sur un
banc y avait 1 tim payne jeudi dernier
au coin de 5,4 m bia anr je crois une
put aller m'asseoir
je vais pleurer tu es des grands s'est
dit j'ai en ce seul et c'est plus grand
pour moi tout ce temps j'ai un
pour jean sentent de l'amont à
billom haut des manteaux dans d'arrêt du
ruisseau sans thani
c'est tout
mais que la peau chaude
[Musique]
beauchamp
aegon mauvaise or ce qu'on va vivre
cette ça va être des techniques à côté
de ce qu'on vient d'un très bon oeil une
vingtaine de films des grands rôles ou
plus petit mais tous marque audi 3 au 10
vieux crée des spectacles en duo ou en
solo dans des salles remplies année
après année et des chansons dont
certaines vont rester pour toujours
[Musique]
les sens
et votre vie monsieur lapointe aura été
beaucoup plus qu'une chanson
la chanson nous avait fait rêver pleurer
la chanson c'est venu naturellement oui
moi j'ai toujours tenté alors de djeddah
virginité fait de l'extradition
j'ai gallup tard à douze
journées de
prières l'apn en famille chez nous et
puis marc lesbre
vial juste avant de dire ça plaît il y
avait félix à la radio je me lève je te
remontre à lui a traversé le riviera
boire
pour toute neuve à mettre au lit le bon
frère arsène brugg abrial se balader 2
vivrait un maroc
et je te préviens eb je l'avais part et
c'est comme ça que les imitations vous
avez aimé ça vous en avez fait beaucoup
au tai chi vos personnages que vous
aimez mieux fin aux bas revenus avec
toujours eu des gros succès en imitant
des grecs puis vous êtes cadre le faire
en crapaud vraiment
ça dépend des circonstances
il ya toujours matière à réflexion
si la voie que vous arrivez à voir
encore exact où elle je le dis pas
parfait j'aurais pu pratiquer si vous
savez j'ai assumé type mal de voir les
bains il reste dans le front
l'importance
mais vigneault sages a été
d'ailleurs faisait d'eux faisait des
vagues physio
pour arriver à imiter géniaux
il s'agit de montrer la voie d'un cran
et puis ça se transforme en dans les
dents ou d'aider les dents
badolo red army voilà vous l'avez dans
les yeux encore cette passion la gelée
vue là j'ai vu le petit globe alors je
suis là maintenant vous êtes juin ont
peu de personnes oui maintenant vous
êtes vieux vous vivez bien votre
vieillesse ne me sens pas vieux port
tout est parfait pour marquer mais j'en
ai mais font font font mal illico des
épaules et parfois des douleurs mais
malgré tout ça moi je restais jambes
d'esprit de coeur
je me sens avez vous des regrets ce que
vous dites non on ne vient pas au procès
évidemment je fait beaucoup d'argent
j'en ai dépensé beaucoup
mais c'est une vie confortable
raisonnable en veut pas plus c'est tout
il ma conjointe personnel c'est une
femme exceptionnelle
après sept ans prend soin de moi comme
si j'étais un petit haut lieu
phare en fait la raison par un tueur
[Rires]
moi je vous jure se sentir
la santé la santé de la santé
pour que je fasse encore un bout mais je
peux par deux membres non non or
voulez regarder enfin vous dit impôt
dessus est pendante 1
[Rires]
de toute façon
rien à faire que je sais bien la mort
emporte stuff pendant un jour où l'eau
un bon transfert prendra pas du tout
aimé vivre
exactement jean lapointe merci beaucoup
fait plaisir patres